peu
[Musique]
c'est marrant joseph du tout comme tours
marié plus bloc le mien c'est normal
j'utilise le savon du cac le savon du
garde les arômes qui dérape
une idée originale pour vos vacances de
la toussaint fête la route des vins moi
j'adore le vin rosé mon mari préfère le
vin rouge c'est pas grave il y en a pour
tous les goûts
faites comme nous suivez la route des
vins la route des femmes vraiment en
vacances
roux route des vins c'est vraiment la
route de vos vacances
[Musique]
madame g à côté de moi une ménagère
madame
avez vous déjà acheté votre lessive
n'ont pas encore j'ai bien je vais vous
faire une proposition
je vais vous donner un baril de lessive
que nous allons appeler x-bow merci
c'est très gentil vous allé l'emporter
chez vous et vous ne donnerez demain à
la même heure vos impressions je suis
très ému je voudrais vous remercier à
demain à demain à la même heure même
endroit le lendemain
madame madame comment avez vous trouvé
notre lessive surprenante je n'ai même
pas eu le temps de rentrer chez moi
enfin apple a rose rentrer à la maison
elle a fait ça fait je suis pas pu
laisser mes allées bien ça c'est un coup
du fln elles font libération de
nouvelles décisions va pas se décourager
pour si peu de choses madame g à côté de
moi un baril de lessive que nous allons
appeler y jouer vous avez vous allé
l'emporter chez vous afin de l'essayer
vraiment à demain madame fln z fond de
libération de nouvelles enzymes
[Musique]
un quorum de pellicule une école si
comme vos amis vous rêvez d'avoir des
pellicules pelli cole en application
régulière
[Musique]
nouveau p l'école existe maintenant en
modèle familial
[Musique]
moi pour avoir de beaux cheveux
j'utilise mejor major est un shampoing
100% naturel fait à base de guano
d'excréments de poule
mais je dors à shampoing 100% naturel
[Musique]
depuis cinq ans j'ai tout le savons
parce que le savon on est nu je trouve
plutôt maintenant ça fait dix ans ça
fait dix ans que je travaille à l'usiné
de savon mon minou et je peux vous
assurer et collez les savons nous nous
sont vraiment des savons pur chat nous
avons en plus il est 100% chercher
[Musique]
problème d'irrigation de rasage blary à
penser aujourd'hui sur chaque rasoa un
pansement incorporé guen
depuis que j'utilise la poudre cola
campement l'appareil dentaire
je n'ai plus aucun problème je peux
enfin croquer la vie à pleines dents
bizarre anna sui bat yachvili bafoue la
zik allways falaise
problème depuis vous à confort bien
notre poids une nouvelle couche avec
france protectrice deux fois plus
efficace
[Musique]
problème de fuite n'hésitez pas
nous avons fort
formidable et nouvelle france
protectrice
on dit d'un adolescent coup de l'âge
ingrat quand il a des boutons des
rougeurs des pointages contre cela il
existe des pommades vous ne l'ignorez
pas maintenant les laboratoires claira
zone viennent de mettre au point une
nouvelle méthode rapide et efficace
consultez directement sur place
nos spécialistes merci que les rats zone
[Musique]
houllier ce mineur c'est à chaque sortie
hanafi louisa necib à reinfeld au dos
pas trash miloud ride
charles burns a surpris ça m'avait le
compositeur a su prouver ou
[Musique]
désirable c'est parfois de l'amour
j'aurai quelques gouttes et je me sens
et résister
faites de moi utilisaient désirable
[Musique]
vva
attention quelques gouttes
[Musique]
observez l'efficacité de la colle y
perdu
attention cette publicité a été réalisée
sans trucage
quand elles l'utilisent
je suis commandé à je suis comme un fou
oui ça tourne c'est magique autour de
moi tout tout chavire
il a cette petite chose en plus qui fait
que lorsque l'on utilise elle est
inoubliable femmes douceur charme
c'est l'efficacité de la colline bergen
[Musique]
attention cette publicité a également
été réalisée sans trucage
[Musique]
longtemps vous n'avez pas voulu parler
de votre volonté
c'était un sujet tabou pourtant elle
subit les altérations dus à la pollution
au froid et au temps qui passe
un homme moderne s'occupe de sa patte
aux bananes viable
toutes les garanties
et de produits nouveaux enfin chez paco
banham une nouvelle ligne de maquillage
pourquoi les hommes soient toujours des
hommes
défaillance sexuelle testé phorm le
traitement efficace pour retrouver votre
virilité de mal aidé mais je vous
attends depuis cinq minutes heures ou
encore jean marie vous pensez que je
suis exténué je n'en peux plus à sa part
je tente en plus et de gens doivent
venir ce soir à la maison je suis bourré
d'action et une bête sexuelle encore et
toujours
alors vous êtes un hélico dans les
appartements 30 avouent belle-maman en
piste et comme à saumur est toujours
prête avec plaisir mon choix
oui testé phorm réellement changer
n'aurait pas fait comme lui utilisé test
iphone
[Musique]
c'est les tickets d'alimentation vous en
avez assez des rations de nourriture que
l'armée vous distribuer tous les jours
et je vous comprends
edwige que diriez vous ce soir si vous
en aviez totalement le loisir et bien
charles henry je ferais exactement la
même chose qui hier mais je dînerai
avec des cadres
[Musique]
de vodka dans un nid de glace moi je
serais plutôt pour du saumon de la
baltique avec un magret de canard du du
périgord je vous connais bien la gourou
mais gourou et surtout que vous n'êtes
vous pas tenté par ses plats de rêve en
ces périodes de sept quais proche
d'arras si vous voulez vous les procurer
on peut les parachutes elle et des prix
seront consentis évidemment
problèmes d'insomnie n'hésitez pas à
faire appel à un sort à cette soirée
des bénévoles sont à votre disposition
jour et nuit pour vous répondre alors
alors est sauvage écoute vraiment des
emmerdeurs qui savent pas quoi faire
au lieu de dormir comme tout le monde
[Musique]